it's must-see tv to watch those two
wherever i'm at on the field i try to
watch the whole picture but my eyes go
right there
two pros that are incredibly blessed
with talent
but they they uh really are technicians
and want to be great and they challenge
each other each and every day and to
watch the respect amongst each other it
looks like during the snap they're
trying to kill each other but then they
help each other up they compare notes
it's really been fun to watch two guys
do who can do it as well as anyone in
this league
and they you know the coolest thing is
to hear them say how much better they're
going to be for it
iron sharpening iron at the highest
level
that is 49ers general manager john lynch
talking about the training camp battles
between new left tackle trent williams
and second year defensive end
nick bosa
which has spawned today's draft the best
intra squad one-on-one battles because
that's all we got no joint practices no
preseason games until the games start
two weeks and three days from today it's
going to be team against team on the
same team that's today's draft i have
this trivia question for chris here it
is in 2012 chris the 49ers had a
first-team all-pro offensive lineman and
a first-team all-pro pass rusher can you
name both
okay so joe staley i'm gonna say is the
first team offense alignment and then
um
justin smith the defensive lineman from
am i right
smith was second team holden smith oh
martin smith you got the right last name
not the right first name
and stanley was second team as well mike
cupati see that one was a little unfair
because you're thinking you're thinking
a blocker on the edge to take on the
ed's rusher but you did all right they
were hey they at least uh all play for
the 49ers all right so i've got the
first pick here um i you know i is it is
it
wait do we want to take williams and do
we want to just do that i want to take
it off the board take them off the board
i mean they're obviously take them off
the board yeah okay take them off fine
all right this is the trent williams and
nick boson memorial draft i am going to
begin with one that i'm afraid if i
don't take it right away you will and i
thought of this one yesterday because
there was a tweet about the defensive
player making a play on the offensive
player and knocking the ball away let's
go to tampa who's going to cover rob
gronkowski in practice how about levante
david and it manifested itself yesterday
and i was afraid you'd lurk on that one
so i'm gonna go right to it i'm going
with the star power and gronk and
levante david david one of the better
linebackers in the nfl who doesn't get
nearly the attention and praise he
should because the team hasn't been very
good maybe this is the year that people
finally realize this guy's pretty good
and at least for now in practice maybe
gronk is realizing this guy's pretty
good yeah no i i uh that was i wrote
down gronk vs tampa linebackers because
devon white's there too they're both
studs right i mean that would be like
you know can't miss tv regardless but
yeah gronk hall of famer those two guys
i mean you could argue that's the best
one of the better linebacker dealers in
football they can run and play the ball
as good as anybody in pass coverage so
all right i'm not mad at you there uh
i'm um uh i'm gonna go to the i'm gonna
stay in the afc east i'm gonna go stefan
diggs versus trudavius white that's one
i'd like to see i mean tridaevius white
all pro corner we know he's one of the
better corners in the game certainly the
best corner there up in buffalo and then
you got a guy like stefan diggs who 1000
yard receiver you know one of the
highest paid in the game great route
runner they're both technicians and have
unbelievable feet so to me that would be
unbelievable to watch with josh allen
throwing them the ball and one-on-one
match-ups and seeing who wins that way
both being feisty uh i i think i kind of
like that
yeah i think that makes a lot of sense
and i think this is just back to that
iron sharpening iron right you have a
great corner
which
nothing against xavier rhodes nothing
against trey wayne's but trudeau's white
he was an all-pro last year and i think
that may help stefan diggs refine his
game just a little bit more and get to
the next level all right i'm surprised
you left this one on the board this one
involves a former 49er who now will be
in indianapolis aha trying to get past
quentin nelson and the rest of the wall
they built a wall there well now they
need something to pierce that wall into
forest buckner so quentin nelson
deforest buckner going at it in practice
i would pay the full price of admission
to witness that man i mean i know you
would damn i should i should have picked
them first you wouldn't have picked your
davies white and digs i i i wanted to do
that one but i was afraid you'd take the
terdavious white diggs one but yes
that's a great one i mean
holy crap does the earth shake when
those two hit each other i mean
seriously they are two of the biggest i
mean quentin nelson is
a block of a body with a block head and
then deforest buckner is just like a
giant i mean he's a giant i i mean i
literally think the practice ground
shakes when those two hit each other all
right gosh damn it you really pissed me
off there all right um
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go to
something similar
and and
two teammates that have never had a face
off until this year all right and that's
where i'm gonna go jason peters fletcher
cox
that to me would be a fun matchup i mean
fletcher cox has played defensive tackle
his whole career jason peters hall of
fame left tackle now he's playing guard
because of the brandon brooks injury so
they're having to face off every day in
practice i mean that that's got to be
unbelievable too there's two hall of
famers going against each other uh i
would pay to watch that i mean peters is
phenomenal unbelievable size can move
about anybody and fletcher cox is one of
the most disruptive defensive players in
football the last few years so uh along
your lines of buckner and nelson i'll
see that and raise it with a peter's cox
combination
and you know every one of our picks so
far yeah involves a new
a new match-up right right even though
peters and cox were on the team together
they didn't cross paths like this in
practice so now i'm i'm struggling here
because there's a lot of different ones
i can do there is
i'm gonna go miles garrett and jack
conklin in cleveland right okay honking
got the big contract yeah garrett got
the big contract who's gonna earn their
contract who's gonna prove their worth
who's gonna be the ultimate alpha at the
top of the mountain and they both end up
better for it when it's time to go play
the games if you are facing a high-end
talent in practice over and over and
over again that makes you better when
it's time to go playing the games you
made that point last week the offensive
line needs to have that edge they need
to have that nastiness they need to keep
the defensive line awake get the most
out of everybody so you're ready to go
to the games and be as good as you
possibly can be no take garrett and
conklin yeah that's a good one i mean it
really is i mean conklin of course
awesome right tackle miles garrett might
be the best pass rusher in the game
right now and and yeah i mean like again
i know we've talked about that but that
is something if i'm a head coach i am
just take i'm on my defensive line every
day to bring the intensity
piss this offensive line off you know
keep driving them crazy by going 110
miles per hour and playing to the
whistle and all those things because
it's the only way they're gonna get
ready for you know prime time here we go
fresh bodies coming in in a regular
season football game and uh i think
that's something to watch out for all
right i'm gonna go to a little wide
receiver db match up michael thomas
marshawn lattimore down there in new
orleans with sean payton dialing up
plays and drew brees throwing the ball
and we know like every two out of every
three plays is going to michael thomas
anyways but marshawn lattimore you know
a top 10 corner in football definitely
one of the few corners that has like
size and strength to match up with a guy
like michael thomas and not be bullied
at the line of scrimmage that's where i
would love to watch that you know yeah
they're two guys that can run and make
awesome cuts and do that but very
physical for their two positions they
play
and i would think that gets pretty uh
heated and competitive so lattimore and
um
michael thomas that's a good group i
think we did all right here you know
when the idea was first planted i
thought oh god this is gonna take some
thought it's gonna take some work
usually the drafts are things that we
just kind of off the top of our head you
start rattling off names you really had
to sit down and think about it where do
you have the great player on one side of
the ball that is going to be
encountering the great player on the
other side of the ball it's got to be
two great players who are bashing right
you know heads every single play and and
it makes both of them better i also had
uh devonta parker and byron jones yep
since byron jones is new to miami and
devante parker last year finally
fulfilling his potential who else did
you have on your list i had devonte
adams and jayer alexander uh i had ryan
ramscheck and cam jordan
um i had hollywood brown versus either
corner in baltimore that i would i would
like to watch and then how about you
know zadaria smith versus bhaktiari up
in uh green bay that would be another
one i'd like to watch
and one other one that i had on there
that really isn't a direct head-to-head
matchup but it kind of bubbled up over
the weekend
jimmy garoppolo and richard sherman and
if you read between the lines of kyle
shanahan's comments about sherman
picking off garoppolo in consecutive
practices
sherman knows what the offense is he
knows where the ball is going to go he's
peeling off of his guy right to pick off
the pass where he knows it's going and
what they ultimately did they went over
the top on richard giving him flashbacks
to devonta adams in the championship
game and sammy watkins in the super bowl
uh to keep him honest so maybe a little
chess match going on between jimmy
garoppolo and richard sherman and we
know it's documented what richard
sherman once yelled at russell wilson
after intercepting him in practice
remains to be seen if richard sherman
yells that at jimmy garoppolo at some
point after picking him off in practice
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports